ragazzi oggi un'altra partita in
champions con lo stesso né su rocket
league spero che vi piaccia un bacino e
buona visione a tutti il desco partito e
non al partito è ne vado ecco massimo
allora offline
bello questo gol iniziale a lui va ma vi
aspetta colpisce è la regola gli serve a
fare un'altra cosa che poi incredibile e
poi così in questo modo lui la ri
colpisce invece un grosso signori ecco
tutta l'ac lato non è vero franco la mia
attenzione vado io ok sono esploso
arrivederci
io ci credo dai se lo aspetta cominciamo
questa carica andano ragazzi tocchettino
bruttissimo palla che va verso l'alto
lui la schiaccia lei ho sbagliato ho
sbagliato io ci sono
bella bellissima questione pista libera
e mandare a quel paese immagino no no no
no il top è naturale baracca si sa che
io sono pronto a progetto queste vinta
se può succedere qualsiasi cosa bella o
anche ovvio all può entrare e allora
vita vite vino è il massimo che loro
possono fare oggi
ok per i nella tua parata come così ok
guarda
roma no no no no niente ma come mai non
può entrare il sistema che un frutto
dovere vantare lunedì
qui adesso ti chiamo 28 secondi terrà 22
tranquilla fissiamo della piccola
picchiamo è un errore del sistema rapido
però non c'è problema più patti comunque
mi stacco in tema di cercare di scrivere
in sat sappilo in tutto questo mentre
giochiamo va bene ok tutto molto tutto
molto bello
tutto giusto
l'ha mandata in avanti e questa è la
nostra ultima azione dove lui fa così
ma diamo ok tu lo sapevi non lo sapevo e
quindi facciamo e vabbè basta è la
regola
io sono fermo no sì
mamma mia lui ha tenuto la regola ha
tenuto la regola della tenuta e allora
sono e allora sono onesti ha mantenuto
la regolazione onesti sono onesti mai
tienila ora l'importante che il sistema
non confonda deve mettere il 3 ma ho
capito ho capito ma parla più cross
perfetto eva non ci sono più ok ok
ancora messa presa presa pressato dai sì
ma che schifo
va bene rendere nel momento non mento
momento non mentono vento momento il
momento no dai bravi e deve rimbalzare
tutto a loro volta ancora non ci posso
credere 1 6 1 contro 1 ha infranto la
regola come hai fatto la regola si
racconta lui no allora avevano perso
hanno perso non importa risulta che si
segnano hanno perso ecco una staccata di
vino nova i telai bellissimo quando il
volo potevano non ce l'ho
[Applauso]
non se la meritavano preciso e sarà
infranto la regola
tieni se vuole un po di burrito la tocco
la metto e gol
guarda questo il gol dello remo pronto
ma col loreo dichiarano i ringo quelli
che giocano a calcio
attenzione perché non ho segnato e
l'omessa spero che sei bellissimo ok
bella aprica allora sono già pronto
guarda come li affetto ma bellissimo ma
che stoppa fatto lui è importante poiché
lo stop atto ma è uscito un cross
perfetto per il mail mia questo diversa
però si cross è uscito da quel tocco
cece giustamente io non ho parole akio
vai tu ti fai sempre tu come quando
siamo alla pari di venezia se tutto va
bene allora tour bettino ok guar aspetta
che perfetta per lui che fa la capriola
carpiata che poi li fa fare il gol
incredibile no perché l'ho toccata dai e
noi ti trovare il focus lo tolgo l'ho
tolto non c'è chi importa
mannaggia
scusami non ho capito che rientra v
mammamia meno male che aveva rotto anche
le scatole nel mentre ride che rompano
le balle perchè non ho capito che se si
rientra devono andare a prendere il
turbo sinistra daje daje daje ma tengono
gliela facciamo gli a secco secco dico
se sai come se questa seguendo che
fastidiosa che la palla crescita ok ce
la faccia ce l'ha tirata bellissimo
perché io vado in pensione che gliela
crossa bravo vado in forte passivo temo
rischio che non si aspettava stocco
quindi siamo in attacco noi poi sono
tutti i tool di e gol
ecco allora che me l'hai persa tutto di
pressing è stata per me erano tutte le
la spa nata la parte sbagliata di
partenza quando lo demolisce sempre top
perché non sai da dove sparano usa manco
lui
va bene i miei mi è rimasta così dai
faccio questo c6 ed altre fermo e ferma
infatti per mero ok ecco perché l'hai
che confermi il palo e il tifo torna ora
perdiamo la nostra vita fa schifo ma
come casi ma ma anche se è tornato ma
perché non deve entrare questa palla
perché a loro si dove sta scritto è il
codice di programmazione che ci ha
scritto ste cose scavando alla pessimo
guarda quanto tempo va bene
eccolo lì gli 11 ragazzi miei anche oggi
il video si conclude qui è il video di
rocket league più bello che non è vero
nel più bello ma è uno dei perchè
siccome siamo a champion è tutto più
figo questa cosa mi mi piace troppo è
troppo bello quindi qualsiasi partita
diventa bella champions che dia che hai
lasciato un bel mi piace un commento e
non ci vediamo come sempre ha
l'occasione da ragazzi
[Musica]